Thank You Nancy these awards are dear to
my heart
winning a student academy award opens so
many doors for me so it's a privilege
and an honor to be here celebrating
these filmmakers tonight tonight we
salute these new voices who come from
just down the street to around the world
including winners from China India
Switzerland hungry Mongolia Sweden
Taiwan and France for each of the
winners tonight I hope that your student
academy award is the first step of many
in your careers and I speak for all of
us at the academy when I say that your
journey thus far inspires us and gives
us hope that you will shape our industry
to reflect the complete mosaic of the
world around us as Nancy mentioned we
had more Academy members than ever
participating in the judging process so
I too would like to extend a personal
thank you to all my fellow Academy
members who gave so much of their time
to make this possible
your involvement was indispensably
indispensable especially with so many
entries this year so thank you for your
commitment to supporting this next
generation of filmmakers we have a
fantastic program tonight with winners
in seven categories for us-based
students we have the animation
documentary narrative and alternative
experimental categories for students at
international film schools we have the
international narrative animation and
documentary categories a bronze silver
and gold medal will be awarded in each
category although a gold only a gold
medal will be awarded in the
international animation International
Documentary and alternative experimental
categories and speaking of the awards
I'm excited to point out that tonight's
trophy presenters Alexandra Achaia and
Jordan Rogers are alumni from the
Academy's gold internship program now
it's time to meet our first presenter to
celebrate the winners and the animation
and international animation categories
we are joined by an extraordinary
comedian actor writer and yes even
podcast host who wrote and starred in
the semi-autobiographical Academy Award
nominated film the big sick you know who
I'm talking about and also stars in
Silicon Valley
please welcome kamal Nanjiani